[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy that always takes the stupid
with him
and this video we're breaking down all
our theories for falcon in the winter
soldier
i'm actually getting the first episode
at 1pm today in the uk
but before it gets here i thought i'd
drop a video so disney don't just think
i've watched that and then put something
out like
here's all my amazing fan theories that
turned out to be true
now i am very excited and just want to
thank you for all your support on the
one division videos which helped me to
get to this point
we're of course doing breakdowns on
falcon and the winter soldier every week
so make sure you subscribe to watch the
eagle-eyed youtuber
that puts you in this snow burden went
upon there anyway with that all the way
thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the video okay so
overall the show seems to be centered
around the graphic novel runs
sam wilson captain america though his
relationship with bucky
isn't that big of a focus the series has
clearly taken some ideas and aspects
from it
and in the run we start with an elderly
captain america
passing the mantle to sam this of course
is very similar the way that end game
culminated
and they clearly put the pieces in place
to follow that narrative
similar to today's current climate sam
finds america more divided than ever
with almost every aspect of society at
the neck of its opposite
due to the rise of nationalism sam finds
himself as a controversial figure
and whereas he thought he would
initially just be fighting bad guys and
attending parades
the series goes far beyond that this is
something i feel will definitely carry
across to the show
and though we don't quite know what
happens yet but but i will in a couple
of hours you suck yes
earlier yeah early reactions from people
that have already seen it
say it's the most political mcu property
yet
i think that judaism breaking the
sokovia accords and also being on the
run for several years
that he will have the mantle taken from
him in exchange for all the charges
against the character being dropped
however he will have to carry on working
for the government along with bucky
and this will be part of the missions
that we see them on now bucky is quite a
dark horse in the show
as it's difficult to predict where his
ark will be going
i kind of hope the guy finds love and a
home as he's pretty much been someone
that hasn't really had a place in the
world
however i feel the show will be
predominantly centered around the fight
for the captain america mantle
and what it actually means to be a hero
that represents a country
in this source material there's even a
bit where the hashtags
not my captain america and take back the
shield trend which i believe are things
that we might see in the show too
it's even possible that because of cap
wanting to lie low as an old man
that sam and bucky will have to pretend
that the character is dead
in the trailers we do see what looks to
be the pair preparing for his funeral
however we also know from behind the
scenes info that chris evans is
returning for a couple of projects down
the line
in the comics they actually reverse the
aging process on him at one point
and this allows him to be a young man
once more which could be what the
mcu ends up doing so that he can come
back i don't know how i feel on that but
from my sources i did hear that the
reason that marvel studios approached
chris once more
is because chadwick boseman was going to
be the next quote-unquote face of the
mcu
sadly the actor passed away which
devastated the comic book community
and as marvel didn't really have an
established name that they could use to
lead the avengers
they went back to chris with a proposal
i think they're just biden their time
until they get that in place
and that they will do something similar
to comics where he's reverted back to
being a young man
now i think that he will most likely be
absent from the series but because he
was never able to officially announce
that sam was the new captain america
whether he's the rightful one will be
put into contention
this will open the door for the us
government which i hope is headed up by
general ross
to appoint their own captain america
namely john walker
now if you're aware of the character
then you'll know that in the comics he
did have the cat mental
but he's more predominantly known as us
agent
u.s agent is somewhat of an anti-hero
and he's been on both sides of the fence
which i think is a motif that this show
will tackle with in the comics he and
sam actually end up facing off against
each other
and this is something that is put in
place by hydra and captain america
who was working for hydra at the time i
think it was complicated
but the point is that sam and us agent
end up fighting
now we know from the trailers that
people appear in hydro jumpsuits at one
point
and this could mean that the
organization is in the show the last
time we saw them they were stealing
crosses pin particles
so they are out there somewhere
potentially walker could be working for
them and he may be organizing attacks
with black smasher in order to swoop in
and save the day so he seems like a hero
now black smasher is someone who too
briefly appears in the run
and though this is an lmd the character
still brings a lot with them black
smasher is a male in the comics
but looks like they've done a gender
swap and set the character up with a
bunch of forces
so that they operate more as a group
rather than one individual
in the source material flag smasher
holds a senator hostage at one point and
reveals that his motives for doing so
are because he believes that nationalism
always leads to fascism
and fascism always leads to war black
smasher sees himself as someone who is
preemptively saving lives by opening up
the borders
tearing down nations and thus allowing
people to truly be
free my prediction is that flag smasher
will be painted out in somewhat of a
sympathetic
light whereas walker will likely be
revealed as being a villain
black smasher will become somewhat of a
hero by the end
i think the show will be heavily steeped
in politics and it will also tackle what
it truly means to be captain america
the source material does a great job of
explaining that cap was never meant to
be a force that attacked people
and they even showcase the part where
steve decides to pick a shield over a
gun to hammer home this message
captain america is supposed to be a
defender not a conqueror
and we will likely see the image of cap
perverted before
sam has to restore the mantle after one
division i feel that the disney plus
shows will very much beside adventures
that you don't have to watch if you just
want to follow the films
therefore they need to leave things like
how they were at the end of end game
and the series will culminate with sam
becoming captain america
once more now in the comics there's
actually a bit where they go to a
village which shield have used to
rehabilitate supervillains
this is actually very similar and
aesthetic to one division
with maria hill using pieces of the
cosmic cube to somewhat alter reality
through this power she has changed the
super villains into people
that believe they are living in an
idyllic america i don't think this
aesthetic will be used as
it's too close to one division to be
something that they will adopt in the
show
but i do believe that in the wake of the
snap that the powers that be will have
tried to re-house super villains
and this could be why zemo is out free
the earth was of course devastated by
thanos's actions
and it's like that the government was
just like well we need
people to to become our workforce so all
the prisoners that survived
will put them on rehabilitation programs
zemo is of course still cry wanking over
that voicemail message
and this is likely driving his actions
in the show
in the trailers we see him visit a
memorial for the people of sokovia
including his family and from the first
looks it seems like he wants to destroy
superheroes across the planet
now we also know that there will be a
scene in which bucky confronts him face
to face
i think that in this moment he will try
and use the mind control words on the
character
but buggy will unload the gun to show
that they no longer work
this is a big moment for the buckster i
think zemo will try and employ these
tactics on other people
potentially he could even brainwash john
walker to have him as one of his sleeper
cells
and this may be a driving force behind
the character turning to the dark side
hashtag hail snyder now we also know
that the series will take us to madrapua
the fictional asian country that is
divided into two sections
high town and low town are both crime
ridden areas
with the former being filled with
mobsters whereas the latter is more of
your typical kind of crimes
like stealing your girl's heart which i
just did
xiaobao anyway this location not only
ties into wolverine
but also the mutants as a whole we know
from behind the scenes information that
the show
changed a big aspect of its story in the
wake of the pandemic
and that this plot line centered around
the virus there's even potential that
this could be terrigen mist
which transforms people into inhumans i
kind of feel like
either them or mutants in general will
be set up in the show
and that this location was picked for
that very reason you know mutants are
coming down the line
and i expect to see at least one or two
of the lesser known ones in the series
at some point
now those are my sort of overarching
predictions based on the comics and
things that we know so far
i know with one division we got a couple
of things right and a lot of things
wrong
but when doing fan theory videos i tend
to look at the comics which is also what
a lot of my one division theories were
based on based on that and
everyone being mephisto it's him it's i
knew it i knew it and mobile are never
one for one with their comics to
adaptations though so i am expecting a
lot of surprises as well as the usual
twists and turns
even though it's only been a week one
division feels like so long ago
i'm glad that we're back with marvel
already now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts and theories on the show
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 31st of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of a marvel 4k boxer
of your choice all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
there's something else to watch then
make sure you check out our spoiler-free
ish review of zack snyder's justice
league obviously
everyone's seen the 2017 version so they
know some of the basic plot elements
which we do discuss
but on the whole we we kind of go over
the film and give our general thoughts
on it
if not then what i don't know what
you're gonna do with the rest of your
day but thanks for sitting through the
video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
i'm off to watch [ __ ] in the winter
soldier
sucker you suck